I'm Mario and today I'm gonna talk about
how we do data science with the Internet
of Things on the edge at hive
let's start with the couple of
definitions Internet of Things is this
recent trend of punty putting an
internet connection into every device
the idea is that in this way we can help
you monitor your house or the car or
even a trainer and on the edge means
that instead of doing the computation on
the cloud we move the computation down
to the device so how did I get here so I
started doing astrophysics looking at
objects like this which are clusters of
galaxies and studying how they bend the
light around them and by studying this
effect we are able to study their mass
and understand their compositions and at
some point I just decided I wanted to do
something different and that the science
was the obvious choice for me because
basically I would be doing the same
thing I was doing before just on
different on houses instead of galaxy
clusters and actually I went to as 2d s
which is the event organized by people
one of the sponsors of this conference
which is which helped me go from science
to data science that's why the name and
I definitely recommend it if anyone is
interested so you might know the hype
thermostat you probably are aware of
other products that we make like the
lightboard smart plugs camera you
definitely don't know hive link this is
a service that can help you if you if in
your family you have another elder
person that lives alone you can use our
devices to make sure that they are fine
and there's nothing happening and and
everything everything is under control
their house we also make Diagnostics for
things like borders in this case or the
devices that detect leaks and I'm
actually gonna give you a better
explanation about this device because
that's what I've been working in the
last year so this is a leak sensor
actually have one here so you the
customer take they take this and attach
it to the pipe that takes water inside
the house and has two temperature
sensors that measure the temperature of
the pipe so with this part here and then
measure the temperature of the ambient
air around the pipe and whenever we see
a drop in the pipe temperature so
difference in between the two
temperatures we detector that's that
means that there is water flowing the
problem with this device it is that it
has to be very cheap which means that
doesn't have much power computational
power and also it's powered by two
double-a batteries so and because of
this reason it keeps the Wi-Fi always
off and only uploads data a couple of
times a day so means that everything we
do needs to be run this need to be
running on this device and only if there
is a problem we can upload data to the
cloud like you might wonder why doing
Internet of Things on the edge a good
example of this could be the Amazon echo
that has to record everything you say
listen to everything you say because
it's waiting for you to say the magic
word and they cannot send everything you
say to the cloud that's gonna be super
expensive for them
that's privacy concern so what they do
is they run a local model that just
listen for the word Alexa and when you
say that we start sending that request
to the cloud worried process your
request and it's same for everyone
interesting in this space the reasons
our internet might not be reliable in
our case
we might our customers want to still be
able to adjust their thermostat even if
there is no internet and if you think
about it running the algorithm on the
device itself can reduce cost and and
speed up everything because that's
basically the ultimate polarization
solution you are running every device
takes care of processing its own data
and and also we in doing this you can
also enhance privacy because you don't
have any data you can make sure that
there's no data leaving the house so how
do we do this we go through this
standard data science approach we
collect data we train a model we
validate we evaluate it and then we
deploy it like this is the standard data
science approach but every of these
steps actually creates a new problem for
us start started for the beginning
collecting data real houses are actually
really really difficult so what we did
is just build a lab and so we had in
Leicester we have a chamber with a lot
of pipes and taps that you see here and
all of our sensors there and we can
control the temperature of that chamber
but actually that chamber is within a
larger chamber that is kept a very low
temperature to simulate the outside
temperature and flow water from the
inner to the outer chamber and go in a
cycle so that we can simulate a real
pipe bringing what cold water inside a
warm house and this is really this was
really important for us because first of
all it's a lab so we control the
environment but also it allows us to
understand the limitations of the
product and understand the physics of
the problem but we quickly discovered
that the lab cannot be a very realistic
can never be a very realistic
representation of an actual house so
obviously what you do you take your
device home there's a saying which is
eat your own dog food
or whatever and that basically means be
your own customer so what we do is we
take our own products home and we just
use them like if your customer will do
so if I take a really long shower I get
an alert from the leak sensor because it
says like oh you have been using water
more than usual but we also try to break
them the same way that they would break
in a real house so turn off my router
and expect to get an alert from the hub
which control device is saying hey
there's no internet well the lot will
come from the cloud which doesn't
communicate with a hub and it's again
it's really important because you as
someone developing a product you want to
know the product really well you want to
feel the same pain that your customer
goes through when they use your product
but again houses are difficult and not
all the houses all of these are
different people do different things
have different schedules so next step is
go to more people so we give devices to
everyone in our team and their friends
first question I ask when someone new
joins is do you know where you're
stopped up is because you're going to
get a leak sensor and basically the one
of the best thing you can do in this
case is ask them to send you a picture
of the installed devices and the
environment around it because when
you're sitting at your desk looking at
the data and you see something weird
it's always good to have a reference
picture say ha that's why maybe that's
what's happening and if you cannot
figure out from the picture what we do
is just look at them because these are
people in our team or are friends of
them now we also send like an email it's
always really important to at this stage
have all the information that you can
have but then it turns out that at this
stage the product is still not finished
otherwise we would have already
release this to the customers so when
you give an unfinished product to your
line manager or CEO of your company you
need to be careful because turns out
that they actually the stakeholders in
this project and if you don't manage
their expectations if you don't realize
that you give them an unfinished product
that you are just testing or still
developing things cannot might not go
very well and we actually have a joke
you know company which is if you are
trial a trial list expect a cold shower
at some point though you didn't need to
go we we had to go to your customers
again everyone is different and real
customers will do unexpected things like
Tony I'm turning up the temperature of
the house by putting the thermostat
inside the fridge and you cannot think
about that stuff you just need to go out
and see what's happening and but also
make sure that you have consent from
your customer to use data from the
budget that they own to improve the
product which is really really
fundamental but then now you will
collect the data and now it's time to
yeah to build the site how how do you
how good you how would your model will
be and so we collected down through
theta like everyone else does in some
problems the ground truth data comes for
free if you're trying to sell the ha if
you want to develop a model the decided
price of a house you can just find a
database with informations on the house
and then the price of what those houses
were sold in our case we don't really
know the properties and the heating
properties of the house and we cannot
afford to send a team of scientists to
every house every tray list house to
measure all of these things so we end up
doing
like I'm guessing a lot of you do which
is manual labeling the problem in our
case is that most of our devices rely on
temperatures and they and we need a lot
of devices to collect the different type
of houses so we have a we have a lot of
data that we would like to label but
data comes slowly every day you can only
collect one day of data from one device
and we need to observe a house for
warmer for more than a year because we
have seasonality and temperature changes
with the different seasons but the other
big problem is that what we are trying
to do we work with devices and
situations and systems that people don't
normally think about you normally don't
think about how your boiler works or how
your pipe works or your pipes work so we
cannot just use a common sense to label
things if you if you are doing object
detection of an image you can just pick
any problem person and have them click
on an image in this case you need to
understand the system before you start
labeling and so we end up just manually
labeling all of this on our own which
means that we actually develop an
internal tool to view the time series
data and label it and this is a really
interesting story because we did this
just to be able to label data and then
at some point we stop labeling data
because we decided we had enough data to
start developing the model and and this
viewer became it's actually become
really very used by a lot of people in
our team because they everyone needs to
access data the femur and other
developer they need to look at the data
of devices sitting on their desk that
they are still got a new femur product
or a trial manager they need to access
the data for their customers which are
they are trying to help support and if
they have any problem so it turns out
this tool which was developed by us just
to label data actually became really
important in across the whole team and
actually no one still understands still
really understand the benefits of this
because it's an internal tool and they
will people will always tell us oh but
it how does this impact the customer and
you have to go through a couple of steps
before you get to the customer and this
is something that's always tricky to to
justify but sometimes for some specific
project we actually found a way to
automate the data collection raspberry
PI's are really cheap sensors and really
cheap and we just put together some very
simple things and attach the pipes or
whatever we were trying to do just
automated the data collection and you
this is a solution that doesn't scale
really nicely because you will have to
we had to have this restore if I just go
around the whole team to collect a
couple of days of data for each of us
but it did the job the other option that
we sometimes go through is if we realize
some of this problem at the early stages
of the design we just designed the
product artwork differently so that we
does the job through hardware instead of
doing algorithm I I think a lot of us
are very lazy that's why we program
things and if I can do something in
hardware why do I need to develop an
algorithm so now we have the data we
know how to evaluate our model let's see
how we deal with a limited computer so
the leak sensor it's very very limited
has 32 kilobytes of RAM very we had disk
space and there's no operating system no
file system as runs on a Wi-Fi and it's
powered by two AAA batteries and I think
about this as a 20 years old device now
some of you might say oh but my Pentium
1 or my computer from the 90s is more
powerful than this but
your gameboy was not the Gameboy is
actually turns out has very similar
specs to the next sense apart from the
processor it's this thing here is much
faster so how do you take a modern
machine learning model and fit it into a
gameboy it's gonna be hard but on the
others on the other side the Gameboy
managed to run pokemon silver so you
should be able to do something so our
goal is to do this right is our goal is
to prove that our machine learning model
can beat the existing heuristics that we
had in place and we always start with
simple heuristic because that first of
all give us a benchmark or something to
beat but also as I showed you already we
need to get as fast as possible to real
houses so we want to have some model
running on the device when we just start
our trials and so we start from this we
start from already a model exist in
there and we want to show that we can
beat it so which means that we don't
need to actually worry about the
constraints of the hardware we just need
to prove that this is doable because at
the a pat the end of the day you don't
know this you don't know that this
machine learning model is actually
better than the see whatever we have in
production and also when you write with
low level C code you need to worry about
all of this stuff and these are all my
all the reasons why I use Python because
I don't have to deal with all of this
and again so it makes us go faster to
missus progress faster and if there is a
problem because we are iterating faster
we can find it earlier so we do this and
we end up with a nice machine learning
model but this model is above our
performance requirement but it's just
too complicated to fit within this
device and so you see
and you think okay how can I improve
this and you find some way maybe to
represent your model differently so it's
still the same exact model but it's more
efficient way of writing it
again we are lazy programmers so we just
do things fast to get something and then
we worry later I will that always let
future mario worry about past Mario but
then at some point you need to make some
compromises and I think about this first
day just lost lossless compression you
just rewrite the model but it's still
the same model but we at some point we
have to do some lossy compression and so
we start to remove pieces of the model
and we think oh we realize oh in Python
everything is a flow every number is a
float as a 64-bit float do we really
need 64-bit can we do it with a four bit
integer can we do the same and that's
worth that ground truth and those
labeling becomes very useful because we
can start taking away pieces and
changing some pieces of the model and
monitor the performance and and see this
point moving down at some point
hopefully this model will cross the
complexity requirement but still be
above the performance requirement and
that's the model that we deploy and so
yeah then you go and deployed a job done
thank you for listening and no that's
not really how it works because your
device is not a server in in your cloud
customer can do whatever they want with
the device we actually
I took this picture this morning
obviously but this actually happened
from one of the people in our team so we
were we had to develop a model to detect
bear installations one of the things
that people do is they people no one
understands pipes in their houses like
Whitewood you so you go to install this
and there's like and there are three
four pipes and people are doing this
online onboarding on the phone and I
just want to get this done so just put
it on random pipe and turns out that one
of that pie those pipes can be hot water
pipe and so we have this model to detect
hot water so one of the people in our
team they wanted to help so they said oh
yeah I didn't get the alert of the hot
water installation but they put it on
the showerhead and I thought yeah maybe
that's true but what we are trying to
detect is hot water coming out of the
boiler directly not on a showerhead
which is probably plaque made out of
plastic so it customer will just do
whatever they want but also it's tricky
because if you have a problem or a bug
in your software that takes the device
of line how do you know what happened
because the device is offline is not
gonna send anymore better for you to
troubleshoot and how do you fix that
anything you you do will affect the
customers and they will be the one
fixing your mistakes you cannot just
delete the instance and rebuild it you
will have to send out emails or do
whatever you do to ask customers to
change batteries or to factory reset
their devices and you don't want to do
that every time you release a new femur
you risk the draining the battery or
your device because device has to
download a large image and process a lot
of stuff and then you always risk
introducing new bugs with every
over-the-air update
so the sad part of this is that we
didn't we don't have any solution for
this doing firm working harder is really
difficult and the risk are great you
cannot fix problems that get all the way
to the customer you have to bother the
customer and have them fix it if it's
those problems so you just have to sit
down and go through all the steps you
need to when you have a new femur you
need to release the femur to QA
and then your QA testers will try and
hopefully catch most of the bugs and
then with what we do is we released this
new firmware to devices we have in the
lab if that's a new algorithm that we
have developed because we want to test
it under controlled conditions or for
example if it is a femur that has to do
with connectivity we are related to our
team members because we want to see how
that femur behaves with different type
of rotors or conditions like apartments
where you have 20 Wi-Fi in range and
device might be confused and when we see
that that works we move to the next
stage which is this extended group of
trail list and finally we get to the
customers that model that would I
briefly mentioned took us nine or ten
months to go through all of this because
we kept finding problems with femur and
going back to square one so in the
meantime we had to find something to do
just a way to wait until our model get
to production
so what have we learned about this get
the product out there as soon as
possible there's nothing you can there's
no way you can think about every single
scenario you need to get it out and wait
and see when it breaks and be prepared
for that work very closely with the
whole team working on that product and
be able to react to any problems that
will definitely arise and do everything
you can to get ground truth data this
here is the single most important step
in your data science pipeline in your
data science work that is what allows
you to build a model to know for sure
that your model works and in our case
for example that what allowed us to just
be able to fit the model inside the
device because we were monitoring this
and you could delete you could delete
your dream model and just return it if
you still have the ground truth data so
that's really the most important part of
everything just do whatever you can and
also initially don't worry too much
about your limitations keep them in mind
but don't worry because you want to
iterate fast you want to get to find the
problems as soon as they arrive and
finally don't skip steps when you're
releasing because filmer is hard and if
I'm interesting that most of these
actually applied to everything not just
IOT on the edge applies to everything so
I don't know feel free to borrow them or
just don't whatever but yeah so this is
it if you are interested get in touch
with me or with my with the Millers lab
we had of data science and thank you for
listening
[Applause]
questions and there's a mic down there
it was just how otherwise
hi so I think you mentioned at the
beginning that this could be used for
elderly people so if it's connected to
the internet I mean yeah exactly so
that's why that's why not a lot of
people are aware we are still slowly
building this you can just go on our
website and see all of the all of this
the idea is that this will notify a
circle of people family things like that
so you need in that case you need an
internet connection to alert people but
that again when you need to alert
someone you need an internet connection
there's no way around it yeah sure
thanks the talk
so did you say at the beginning that the
purpose of the device was to detect
leaks so I was wondering in your
training group of like the people at
your company and friends I guess you
don't have many leaks in that time so
how do you deal with that sort of that
sparsity of sort of positive cases yeah
so it's actually interesting because the
the aim of the product evolve with time
and so we end up with them redefining a
little bit our requirements so even
though it's still called leak sensor
it's also very good at detecting any
usage so we basically have a bungee or
just a duration so even though sometimes
real leaks are rare we still label a lot
of things that are probably not the
leaks are people washing their car
things like that and that actually
increases the frequency and we didn't
worry too much about this being one and
they represented the class because it
turns out that if you include it if you
include this then you end up with it's
not a huge problem anymore
so you basically you include usage as a
detection of alley
yeah because from our point of view we
just see water flowing we have no way to
distinguish between the two so we only
put like a time limit so in your in the
app you can say
alert me if you see if I see water
flowing for more than 15 minutes or 60
minutes it's very limited device and so
in that case again this doesn't become a
problem anymore and we just didn't
bother with it hi so what's the need to
have so much computation on the device
itself like what what model are you
building that you couldn't just you know
push the data to the cloud and then have
alerts generated all in the cloud so so
it depends on on the on the product for
example for the leak sensor because it
needs to be cheap
it runs on double-a batteries you also
don't want to have something wired those
connected to your pipes and that means
that we cannot leave the Wi-Fi on it has
to be always off and so if there is a
leak we need to be able to detect the
leak when the device is offline we
cannot wait for advice to wake up sends
data and then six hours later detect the
leak so do you end up fitting a
different every customer ends up fitting
a different model that might have been a
plan at some point we actually have the
model itself is global but one of the
features that go into a model is learn
for different customers
when you were training your model in the
cloud when you just had to detect the
use that you said you had to manual able
because he was no AppData from Holmes
and I was wondering if you had access to
the data from the smart meters that they
had I don't know if she would then you
would potentially be able to calculate
it yeah so that's something that we
thought about a lot and the problem with
the smart meter data is just the
frequency with which the data is sampled
and so that's just too large for us
device collects data much much faster
than I see anything like that okay yeah
very it is a good gone through for us
for question so you mentioned a lot of
times that you went back and forth
between development and QA so apart from
the issues that come from actually
developing a fever which like it's a
task of its own menu it was related to
prototypes done in Python then converted
into C bugs in the process back and
forth so I'm guessing that before my
time in this project there was a lot of
debt I worked on this for a year and a
half and there was only one time where
we we were the reason why we had to go
back but otherwise it was mostly
connection problem but again it's the
model is actually not super complicated
and we do have data historic data so we
just try to do oh yeah sorry I know I
got it one of the things that we need to
make sure that our model was actually
implemented correctly is that we
produced so what we do is we develop the
model in Python and then we end over the
model to software engineers to implement
it
if it is in a platform or in this case
in C and actually I call this different
person but actually the software
engineer was actually the scientist who
know how to write
see and when we did when we do this we
actually produce unit tests that are the
input and expected output from the model
that we have trained and so we this
should this should this mix with this we
make sure that what is implemented
either in the cloud or in on the device
is what we have trains we know so
similar process to shadowing models so
you put them side by side and now you
child on the output side the same
question how long does it take to go
from Python to see I'm a PI the
prototype to see production model didn't
take too much
Stack Overflow is always near now we
will seriously like that's what we did
we just googled how to convert circuit
learn to see there was some things like
okay that works yeah obviously we put
you test things and we tested every step
we tried to compare input and output and
make sure that everything was how we
thought it was
so I was wondering what's the hardware
lease and design frozen or did you have
any sort of feedback to that sorry the
hardware design the requirements for the
hardware were you able to define your
own requirements or for the other
you mean no abilities of the hardware
have a little memory processor kind of
sensors I'm I'm not sure there is
definitely feedback but at this stage
the product is a little bit mature so we
kind of in for this specific probably
were given that but we're actually
thinking about new additions and we are
involved a lot with that because we have
this lab so we can go and try the new
hardware there so there is we try to
keep everything like the whole team very
close and involve everyone in
decision-making good thanks to the talk
I thought it was really interesting with
a sensor in hardware this this small do
you start having you know do you have to
have security considerations even for a
product this small order stuff yeah you
always have to have those because at the
end of the day even though this model
runs on the device we still send data to
the cloud because we want to make sure
that everything is working so you always
need to be aware of everything it some
people might think oh but my temperature
is not sensitive but it's everything you
do in your house it's your own business
and everything should be super secure
and protected thank you
I don't know the next speaker
how do you deal with connectivity issues
if the device is in the basement for
example so with we asked the customer is
your wife as you're stopped up in reach
of the Wi-Fi you can always say yes and
and in that case it doesn't work again
when you when you have a product that
requires let's build around notifying
someone you need the internet
connectivity there's no way around it
[Applause]